ah yes
I wanted to do this
um
the proust questionnaire so [ __ ] the
whole of it anytime someone one time I
asked a guy what were you read and he
said proust and I was like you're right
you're out
no more friendships
the Press questionnaire has its origins
in a parlor game popular
popularized although not devised by
Marcel proust
the French essayist and novelist who
believed that in answering these
questions an individual reveals his or
her true nature
wow here's the basic process
questionnaire I mean you know to think
this okay there's 35 of them so what is
your idea of perfect happiness being
with my family
um
and security
what is your greatest fear sharks
no honestly not my greatest fear is
probably
hmm
not being able to provide for my family
what is the trait you most deplore in
yourself
um I hate that I am
I'm terribly insecure
about and I I and I oh I hate being
alone
I really don't like that I try to do
everything but I'm [ __ ] already gonna
cry it's [ __ ] number three okay
um what is a trait you most deplore in
others I I can't I cannot stand when
somebody is
um
oh man I don't like when people are
what's yours by the way think about this
with me I don't like when people are
um
[Music]
don't know how they're coming across
that's so annoying it's so annoying when
somebody thinks that they're [ __ ]
badass and they're a dork or some [ __ ]
is that surfacy whatever that's how I
don't that's what I don't like
uh being mean is shitty too which living
person do you most admire
um
it's it's probably Kristen
or
[Music]
um
it's probably Kristen
maybe a family member too I don't know
she's just fantastic what is your
greatest extravagance what does that
mean what if I was just like this and I
showed like a golden [ __ ]
Cape I just bought this for 14 million
dollars uh greatest extravagance I don't
know man shoes
spending on shoes what is your current
state of mind
ah I'm a bit depressed but I'm okay I'm
getting through it
what do you consider the most overrated
virtue
oh that's a good one God this price guys
really onto something you know the most
overrated virtue
um
hmm
I'm going to Google virtue just to make
sure I have it
correct
virtue
definition
okay okay oh okay most considered
overrated virtue
um oh I got it sharing your feelings
just [ __ ] you don't have to do that
sharing with two people
you know these oh it's okay to cry on
Instagram [ __ ]
hey
Zoom your therapist
[ __ ] 5.1 million people have to see
this [ __ ] you know
um on What occasion do you lie
to spare someone's feelings
um yeah
used to lie a lot what do you most
dislike about your appearance oh that's
a good one [ __ ] dude why do I want to
answer this to you guys this should be
in private uh
I don't like I don't dislike [ __ ] about
my division maybe I want I would like a
thicker butt dude I would like I would
like a little bit of a [ __ ] my
thicker legs dude that's what I want I
don't like my skinny ass legs which
living person do you most despise welp
not answering that one which is the
quality you most like in a man
um
[ __ ] size no I like
um
Integrity it's tough man because I
admire that and sometimes you know I
struggle with that I want to be and you
know in my life I have struggled with
that
um I admire when a guy live lives for
something uh above himself a greater
purpose and um you know sometimes I feel
like you know it's hard to find that
you know just day by day uh but mine's
my family and you know
uh what is the quality most like in a
woman I really love when a woman can
laugh at herself
um I love uh when they are
um uh very giving whatever the opposite
of like cheap is like uh
giving
what's that word
um generous
um which words or phrases do I most
overuse probably dude and
um
I don't know Kristen always says I say
look a lot like look and that's annoying
as [ __ ] I would think uh who is your
greatest love of your life oh come on uh
when and where were you happiest
I would say they date Calvin's born
um which Talent would you most like to
have
uh
uh oh [ __ ] man
I don't know man I really like being
funny
what talent would I most like to have
I'd like to sing a little bit better
just to [ __ ] be that much funnier
when I absolutely kill it uh but oh then
that goes back to funny so if you could
change one thing about yourself what
would it be
um I would change that I don't want to
be an addict I don't like being an
addict
it's hard it's really hard what do you
consider your greatest achievement oh
being uh with my
being able to turn my life around and be
there for my my family my greatest
achievement yeah 100 just being
you know working on being a better
person and being a better person God
damn this is so deep I I don't like this
it makes me feel uncomfortable if you
were to die and come back as a person or
thing what would it be oh dude uh
oh man
a [ __ ] Delia dude I love Delia's I
love delias just have me come back as
some kind of Delia
um where would you most like to live
that's great
I think the Greater Los Angeles area
though you know I'm not necessarily in
the thick of it but like Pasadena or
something like that would be nice what
is your most treasured possession hmm
God that's a good one too
I don't know I don't even know I don't
think about this stuff my most treasured
possession
uh
uh some kind of I don't know
what am I ever like oh yeah I like this
[ __ ] I don't know I'd have to think
about that what do you regard as the
lowest lowest depth of misery
uh like for me or just regular dread is
the worst if that counts just dread
waking up and not knowing why you feel
it
is the worst dude can't even get out of
bed uh or my OCD is the lowest depth of
Mr Misery uh what is your favorite
occupation stand up what is your most
marked characteristic funny what do you
most value in your friends uh loyalty
who are your favorite writers all right
this is too many what is your motto no
um anyway do that
keep going you think it's good you like
you like you like it yes yes one fire
likes it all right we'll keep going yeah
okay there's a few more
um
27 I'm on 27. who are your favorite
writers uh okay I like uh I I gotta
still say okay so I love
um
uh uh JD Salinger and I love um ready
stanellis Bernie sandals go fall when I
read him
uh sorry process not you who is your
hero of fiction
um
Batman I like that he was able to
[ __ ] kick ass with no superpowers
which historical figure do you most
identify with Tupac Shakur I love him
I'm not straight but I love him uh who
are your heroes in real life
probably my father
okay not gonna cry
um what are your favorite names
I really like Calvin that's why we named
him Calvin
um I love the name
um
my dad's name I love Bill William
um I love the name Chris
Matt's cool but it's also a thing like a
mat like so I don't really love all that
um
uh you know there's some cool names out
there Kevin and [ __ ]
that always makes me think of the
[ __ ] uh
uh Family Guy where they're like what is
your
where he was trying to get into the
locked room and it was like you can get
into this locked room if you answer one
simple question and they say what is the
worst name and Peter Griffin says Ah
Keith and it goes
dude Keith is a [ __ ] name though for
real what is it that you most dislike
um
probably
ah the the woke [ __ ] culture of
bandwagoning and
making people want to [ __ ] kill
themselves because they did something
wrong how would you like to die old age
man who the [ __ ] says anything but that
old age
even though sometimes times get dark uh
and what is your motto come on
life reps
um well that was pretty interesting do
that you say a lot about yourself what
is it [ __ ] of course now it says oh
this is I and then I if I had to fill
this [ __ ] out and then the therapist is
like oh it says here that you're you're
a serial killer
um that was kind of interesting though
um [ __ ] got me emotional
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]